Yan asks how do I create interesting
content for a boring subject such as a
hardware store any ideas thanks Yan a
hardware store is very far from boring I
mean we've talked to people that are
asking about highways and cement and all
sorts of things and I have no idea how
you think that a hardware store is
boring when you're selling tools
something that tons and I mean tons of
people are actually passionate about so
you know the fact that you've
categorized it as boring makes me say we
have to work on your mindset because you
need to open it up because construction
and homes and DYI do it yourself all
these things are happening right now and
I would argue that a bunch of people who
are watching right now are going to
leave comments in YouTube saying that is
far from boring so I would say it's not
boring the content is quite easy and uh
get your ass to
it